Dr. Jack Van Horn: Good morning, everyone.
We should probably get started.
I wanted to say that this is
Jack Van Horn from the BD2K
Training Coordinating Center
at the University of Southern
California.
And I'm delighted to
introduce our section one
lecture this morning on
Data Indexing and Retrieval
by Dr. William Hersh,
who's professor
and chair of the Department
of Medical Informatics
and Clinical Epidemiology at
the Oregon Health and Science University.
We're delighted to have
Bill here this morning,
and we look forward
to his presentation.
Bill, stage is yours.
Dr. William Hersh: OK thank you, John.
Is my voice volume OK?
It's perfect, thank you.
OK, [LAUGHS].
Well, thank you for inviting
me to give this lecture,
and I'm honored to be part
of this chorus, which is just
a further recognition of the
importance of data science
and biomedical informatics
in biomedical research
and for NIH.
See if I can get my
slides to move here.
OK.
So today is really
an introduction
to this whole section, and
the following five weeks
after today, we'll drill
down into the topics
under the second bullet.
And I was asked to address
this issue as a whole,
so I thought I would step
back and give the big picture
in an area that is derived from
information retrieval or IR
or Search.
Many of you know this is
an area I've been doing
research for several decades.
And as we transition from
looking to find documents
towards looking to
find data, there
are some issues that we
need to address and make
some modifications
in what we do.
So I thought, in this
lecture, that I would first
give the big overview
of Search and drilling
down into areas such as
content indexing and retrieval.
Probably some of this
is familiar to you
all, and certainly probably
almost everyone listening
has done Search.
The way I decided to
address the topics
was to give just a brief
high level overview
and then ask some
questions that you
could think about when
you actually listen in
to those lectures
in the coming weeks.
A little bit more about myself.
As John mentioned, I'm
chair of the Department
of Medical Informatics
and Clinical Epidemiology
here in the School
of Medicine at OHSU.
If anyone has any questions,
feel free to email me.
I have a website,
which actually has
a link to a PDF of these slides
and the references that I cite.
Also sent that to John, if they
want to put it on their site,
as well.
I also write a blog called
the Informatics Professor,
and I'm not a real heavy
duty Twitter person.
But I do tweet and
follow things on Twitter.
I've also written a book.
It's actually getting
a little aged,
but the basic
principles are still
sound on information
retrieval, which
was actually published in 2009.
So in addition to lecturing
on this topic today,
I'm actually hoping to
demonstrate something else,
which is related to the grant
that my group here at OHSU
has from the BD2K program.
We're one of the--
I believe it's
up to about 12 or
15 centers funded
to do curriculum development.
Ours is under the Open
Educational Resources
Initiative, and we received
that grant, actually,
a couple years ago.
And I give a link
here to our page,
which is slowly filling
up with the content
that we're aiming to develop.
So again, I'll give an overview
of information retrieval,
introduce the specific topics.
And then the secondary aim
is to actually demonstrate
what one can do with open
educational resources.
In fact, essentially what I've
done for this lecture is pull
slides from two of our
modules-- one on information
retrieval, one on ontologies.
And then I've modified
them to fit this.
And that's the purpose of
open educational resources
is for people to be
able to, not only
use the materials to learn
from, but also to teach.
And under a Creative
Commons kind of license.
So let me start then with data
and information retrieval.
I'll show you some
figures that I
think give a perspective
on what we're
doing when we're trying to
do information retrieval--
the process, the
knowledge discovery,
and then some of the
challenges in the modern era
for information retrieval.
So I like to think-- I
know that last week Dr.Musen
talked about
the lifecycle of data.
I actually have a similar.
This figure actually
comes from my book.
For me to try to figure
out what it is we're
retrieving when we're looking up
scientific information and now
increasingly data.
So most scientific knowledge
is generated through research,
usually new research.
In this day and age,
research can not only
be things in labs, things
in clinical trials,
but of course re-analysis
of data-- things
like systematic reviews
and metaanalysis
or going into either
biological or clinical data
and doing further analysis.
If we want to publicize
that research,
we write up the
results into a paper,
submit it for publication
to, usually, a journal
or conference proceedings, goes
through a peer review process.
It may be rejected, and you
have to revise it and resubmit.
And sometimes you get caught
in that cycle quite a bit.
But if you're persistent and
you have decent research,
it will eventually be
accepted, and then you'll
publish it, typically in
a journal, although that
may be changing over time.
When you do publish it, you
see some dotted lines here
of things that may happen.
So you may actually have
to relinquish copyright.
That's a big issue.
That could probably take
an hour in and of itself.
I won't address in today's talk.
Your work may make it into
secondary publications--
reviews, text books,
things like that.
And of course, if your
research is any good,
it will generate new questions
that need to be asked,
or it will generate
data that others
may want to further analyze.
These days, particularly
biological, like genomic data,
tends to go into
data repositories,
less so clinical
data, though that
will be changing over time.
So, historically, the focus
of information retrieval
has been to look
for those documents.
But now, of course, there
is the potential ability
to actually find [it].
The way I look at information
retrieval is as a funnel--
and, again, this
comes from my book--
where the process of
information retrieval
is where we really are searching
over all the literature,
like when we go PubMed,
and in the process,
we find some possibly relevant
literature with our search.
And then we select what's
definitely relevant.
But, of course, we may
want to do more with that.
We may want to
actually do text mining
on the descriptions
in the papers,
or we may want to
get at the tables
or even ultimately to the data.
We may want structured
or actionable knowledge.
That's more the domain of
information extraction and text
mining.
Those processes usually make use
of natural language processing,
machine learning,
other kinds of things.
The information retrieval
is-- I wouldn't call it
a solved problem--
but it's a problem
that there is a lot of
widespread, commercialized
solutions, whereas information
extraction text mining
is something that is
starting to emerge.
There are some
commercial companies,
but there's also a lot
of research systems
that do that, as well.
So focusing in on the process
of information retrieval, what
we're ultimately aiming
to find is content.
And I use that word
"content" deliberately
to really cast the net broadly--
anything from papers to images,
videos, and of course, data.
In order to be able
to find that content,
we have to go through
an indexing process.
I'll talk about that in
more detail in a moment,
some way of basically generating
metadata, data that describes
data about the content.
So when we have
that metadata, we
can then have users who
are seeking to retrieve
things, enter queries.
And they enter queries in the
metadata and a search engine—
and I'm sure you're all
familiar with search engines
like Google and
PubMed-- will match
that metadata from the
queries to the content,
so the user can retrieve.
Information retrieval,
when I started
working in this
field in the 1980s
was something that
you oftentimes
had to go to a librarian
and or used to pay money
for dial-up internet
or to dial up actually
into the systems themselves
over time sharing
networks, CompuServe, AOL.
Now of course, all of us
have computers and phones,
and essentially everyone
has used a search engine.
In fact, some browsers,
like Apple Safari,
will-- if what you type into
the URL box doesn't match a URL,
it'll throw you into
a search engine.
And people search for
health-related information.
And the latest statistic,
71% of internet users,
meaning 59% of all adults
search for information, 35%
using it for self-diagnosis.
And of course, this is
not just a US phenomenon.
It comes from the entire world.
Search is considered an
integral application.
Many software packages have
Search built into them.
Enterprises develop
Search capabilities
across their assets
and so forth.
And we even have search
engine optimization,
something those of
us doing research
in the early days
never thought of,
where people would be
willing to pay money
to have their search results
move up higher in the rankings.
Fortunately, some of us
have last names that are not
that common like H-E-R-S-H.
So I, fortunately, have
never had to pay money
to have my rankings elevated.
If you type my name into
Google, I come right at the top.
And just to show you how
mainstream-- I'm sure many,
if not all of you, have been
so these search systems.
PubMed and Google are
probably the-- PubMed
for anything biomedical
and Google for anything.
We also know that
access to information
is really part and parcel of
health and biomedicine now.
InCell, back in 2003, said
that biology's becoming
an information science.
The old days of capturing things
in your laboratory notebook
is being replaced by
databases and spreadsheets
and all other kinds of things.
We hear about pharmaceutical
companies competing
for informatics talent.
On the clinical side,
we have clinicians
trying to keep up with the
knowledge of their field, where
they're in an era when there
is about 75 clinical trials
and 11 systematic reviews
published each day.
And searching is ubiquitous.
It's even part of--
for those of you
who are familiar with
electronic health records--
the meaningful use regulations.
And one of the
requirements is the ability
to do a text search over
electronic health record notes.
So searching is pretty common.
But we have some challenges.
We perhaps, 20, 30
years ago, there
was not that much
information online.
Now we had the opposite problem.
We're overloaded.
We have challenges searching
because there are multiple ways
to say the names of diseases,
the names of genes, symptoms.
Searching can be a
challenge when there's
so much information out there.
Of course, there is also
the converse problems,
where we have many
words and terms that
have multiple meanings.
The word "cold."
It could be the temperature
cold, the disease cold,
and so forth.
Or there was just
paper in I think
it was Nature within the
last few weeks about how--
or maybe it was TLOS-- but
how spreadsheets can mess up
genes analyses because
genes like apr-1
are converted by things like
Excel into the date April 1st.
So then, of course, apr-1
has multiple meanings.
And then this other
issue-- again, which
is a very interesting topic to
me and probably many of you,
but it's just beyond
the scope of today--
is how we balance that
open access, making
the fruits of
research, most of which
are paid for by the
government, freely available
versus the real cost of
producing it and maintaining
it.
So these are some of the
challenges we'll face.
I'm not going to solve
all these problems today.
So let me drill a
little further into some
of the aspects of
information retrieval.
Let me start with content.
And, again, I use
that word "content"
in a real broad sort of way.
So back in the 1960s,
70s, even into the 1980s,
networks were slow.
We mostly connected
by telephone modems.
Discs didn't have
that much capability.
So most of the
content we search on
was abstracts, and mostly
of journal articles.
But then, as the technology
improved, the network bandwidth
improved, the whole system
became more affordable
for individuals and
organizations to connect to.
And these aren't really
in timewise order,
but they're sort of.
We then moved to full text.
So instead of the
abstracts now, we
could put the whole
article online.
We could move things
like text books.
We could publish reports.
And so those are
predominantly text based.
Still the memory and bandwidth
requirements are modest.
But then we started
moving into hypermedia,
where we have web
pages, images, sounds,
and videos, and so forth.
And the bandwidth requirements
and storage requirements
started to increase.
And then also the development
of structured selection--
textbooks that are linked across
each other, large databases,
compendiums, and so forth.
And so these-- the
middle bullet--
those content materials have
been increasing in size.
And in fact, we pretty
much take them for granted.
And then now we move
into the new era,
when we can no
longer just publish
the results of our research,
but we can publish our data.
And if you read the medical
literature or any other source,
there's controversies
about how readily available
should data be.
Someone coining the term
research parasites, which
made a lot of people upset.
What are the issues behind
making data available?
I won't comment on the
economic or political issues,
but I will comment on the
technology and informatics
issues around data retrieval.
So I talked about content.
Let me talk a little
about indexing.
Indexing is critical
because we need somehow
to be able to find the
content we're looking for.
And this is where
metadata comes in.
Data about data.
We assign metadata
to content items,
and we can do it in automated
fashions or using manual
methods.
Automated systems, things like
Google, things like the word
search in PubMed,
will very easily
pull out the words in the
records or the documents
and so forth.
And we can assign
measures to them that
allow us to rank the output.
Any undergraduate
computer science student
can write algorithms to extract
out the words of a document.
It's a relatively
known thing to do.
We've also, since the beginning
of things like Medline,
had manual indexing,
where there are experts
who, in the case of Medline,
follow a protocol where they
assign terms from a
controlled vocabulary,
in this case MeSH of the
medical subject headings,
and they follow a
protocol where they
look at different parts of
the article in a process that
takes about 15 to 20 minutes
because there are so many.
So they focus on things
like the introduction
and the conclusion and
the figure legends.
And then they assign anywhere
from 5 to 10 MeSH terms,
and a few of them get
designated as central concepts.
So those are assigning subjects,
what the content is about.
But there's other
attributes we might want.
For example, we might
want to know the author.
I actually do a fair
amount of author searching.
Oftentimes, I know I want
to go find someone's paper
that was published
in a certain place,
so I enter their author name.
And in PubMed, when you
type two words together
and the second word only
has one or two characters,
it will try to map
that into an author.
We might want to know the
source, the journal that it
came from it.
It was a report that's published
by an institution, et cetera.
We might want to know
the publication type.
This is particularly important,
well, in a number of places,
but one of the major
ones is with clinicians
who are looking, for example, to
make an evidence based decision
and use a randomized
control trial.
There's things like secondary
source, in the case of Medline,
and this is where
we have linkage
to gene resources, protein
resources, all the other myriad
of databases that are
available through the NLM,
the National
Library of Medicine,
and other organizations.
We may want to know the grant
number for whatever reason.
And then, of course,
the location.
The bibliographic
databases in the old days
told us where to
go into the library
stacks to find the journal.
Now the location gives us
a URL or basically a DOI,
a digital object identifier,
that's converted into a URL.
So right from the Medline
record, we can click a link
and go to the
publisher's website
to retrieve the article.
And sometimes we run into
paywalls and so forth.
But at least there's a link
to where we can go get it.
We don't have to go
searching through the stacks
in the days of old.
A little bit more about MeSH.
MeSH-- well, all
indexing vocabularies,
they usually consist
of control terms.
They're usually
organized in a hierarchy.
I have a figure on this slide.
It's basically a vertical
slice through a piece of MeSH.
MeSH has 16 trees, anatomy,
diseases, chemicals, and drugs,
one of which is diseases.
And you see, I'm basically
traversing down the hierarchy--
cardiovascular diseases,
vascular diseases,
hypertension, et cetera.
And all in all, there's
about 26,000 terms in MeSH,
and then there's a
number of synonyms.
So you can express the
terms in different ways.
And if you ever want
to do a look at MeSH,
there's a nice website that the
NLM keeps as basically a MeSH.
browser.
Onto the retrieval side.
Remember the purpose of doing
indexing is so we can retrieve.
And there is really two
kind of general approaches
that search systems use.
One is the requirement for
Boolean operators—“and,”
“or,” and “not.”
“And” helping you to
narrow your set,
“Or” to express things
in different ways.
“Not” is less frequently
used, but sometimes we
use it to filter
out certain things.
Or what we see more commonly
is natural language systems,
where we don't actually have
to explicitly type the Boolean
operators, although
oftentimes things are done.
For example, in
Google, the default
is to do an “and” between
all of the words
that you type into Google.
There's ways to override
that, but that's
Google's basic function.
The Boolean systems
basically give us sets.
Sources like PubMed
will sort them
by reverse chronological order.
With natural language
systems, we usually
get the results ranked.
And so when you do a
Google search or really
any system that uses
natural language searching,
the results of
the search will be
sorted, sometimes by the word
occurrence and frequencies,
of words that are common to
what the user has entered
and what's in the content,
or the use of in-links, which
of course was popularized.
It really was the basis of
the Google search engine
and is part of the
reason why it works
so well in the setting
of the World Wide Web
with billions of documents--
how many pages point to you.
And that's one of
the things that
goes into how Google
ranks its results.
So over the years,
they've added a lot more,
and now it's all proprietary.
But the original
feature of Google
was that page rank
algorithm that
was described by Brin in 1998.
A few more comments
about metadata,
which is data about data.
So it tells us what
the data items mean.
There's different
types of metadata.
We've mostly been talking
about descriptive metadata
that enables us to
discover or identify it.
But there's also structural
metadata that describes how
the data itself the
structure, the fields that
are used and so forth, and
the administrative data
on how it's managed.
And this can include
rights management-- so
who can access
it, when and how--
and also how it's
been preserved, how
it's been archived and stored.
When we talk about IR
systems, the best example
is literature indexing
and annotation.
But metadata exists for
databases of almost any kind
of computerized resource.
One final question
I'll just cover briefly
is how do we know how well
we've done when we search.
I've actually-- I
and many other people
who work in
information retrieval--
I was very interested
in this question
and have done research
looking at it.
There's a lot of questions
we can ask if we want
to know how well a search is.
Is a search system used that
we make available to users?
Are they satisfied?
A lot of the
research has focused
on relevant information--
how much relevant information
did they find.
Another question we
may ask is did they
complete their desired task.
And I've looked at that,
mostly from the standpoint
of clinicians over the years.
When we're looking for
relevant information,
there's the well-known measures
of recall and precision,
recall being of the proportion
of materials out there that
are relevant, the proportion of
content, what do we get back.
So retrieved that relevant
divided by relevant.
And then perception is the,
of what we actually retrieved,
how much is relevant.
So retrieved that relevant
divided by retrieved.
And there's a whole
bunch of issues when you
use these measures in research.
And so I won't go
into that detail,
but you can search
the literature
in medicine, computer
science for all kinds of work
that's been done in this area.
So let me-- I'm hoping to
leave a little bit of time
for questions.
And so what I was going to spend
the rest of the lecture doing
was going through the
topics of section one.
And again I'm going to present
it to you, asking questions.
And I know each of the lectures
in the following five weeks
will go into details.
And maybe this,
for you, could set
the stage for what
you might want
to hear when they go into much
more detail on each of these.
So next week's lecture is
entitled Finding and Accessing
Datasets, Indexing
and Identifiers, so
a lot of what I've
been talking about,
but focused on data collections.
And there's a number of emerging
sites that are basically
search engines for data now.
And I list two
here, although I can
think of many more
off the top of head.
But DataSite was one
of the first ones.
It's a way to find datasets.
And DataSite is not
limited to medicine.
It covers many topics.
There's another one
that's more focused
on medicine from the
bioCADDIE Project, which
I believe the speaker next
week is from that project.
Datamed.org, that lets you
search for collections of data.
And why would you
want to find data?
Usually because you may be
interested in doing research
with it.
You want to replicate
the results of a study
from the data that they
collected and so forth.
And so I think the question to
think about here is, I think,
most information retrieval has
been done with information.
And as we move from
information to data,
are there any issues
that become unique?
It turns out there are with
datasets in terms of-- whereas,
for example, a journal article's
published, and then it's done.
Maybe there might be
an erratum sometimes,
or perhaps it's even retracted.
But by and large, it
becomes a static document.
Datasets might not
always be static.
They might have snapshots
at different times.
But those are some
of the things we
need to know when we're creating
data retrieval systems to set
up and allow the searcher
to be able to search
on those sorts of attributes.
Another issue, or
the second topic,
will be data curation
and version control.
Again, data curation
can sometimes
become a little more
challenging than, say,
just journal articles because
datasets have a context
and they may grow or change.
But it's important
to remember that data
doesn't exist in a vacuum.
Data gets collected
when there's usually
some sort of experiments
or observation going on.
The only data in the
dataset that is collected
is that which was collected.
And so, sometimes, when
people do experiments,
they may not collect
certain types
of data that actually
could have been collected,
or perhaps they
just couldn't have
been collected because
they didn't think
about collecting those things.
Probably every researcher has
done at least one experiment
in their lives when they
think to themselves, oh,
why didn't I measure
this or that when
we were doing the experiment.
So the figure here, it
comes from University
of California Merced website.
I was looking for a good picture
of research data curation,
and I found this one.
And this really
highlights the challenges.
When we do an experiment, we
need a data management plan.
In fact, NIH grants
now require that,
and there's a lot of detail
that goes into storage.
We collect the data, we have
to describe it, analyze it.
And, eventually,
when we're at least
done with the
initial experiments,
we move on then to archiving
the data and publishing.
Now, historically,
researchers have
archived data in their own
files, hopefully at least
electronically, though
that's not always the case.
Probably not so much anymore.
But, oftentimes, those
archives are private.
The study is published,
although, increasingly,
researchers have to
publish their data,
especially in the
omics world, less so
in the clinical
world, though we're
seeing a lot of conversation
going on about that.
And of course, as research is
done with extractions of data
from electronic health records
and other clinical data
sources, not to mention all
of the personal devices,
wearables and stuff
that people have.
So lots of data.
Usually the research
question comes
at the beginning of the study.
And I suspect that's
what's actually meant here.
But again, when we get data,
we then can ask new questions.
Now we always have to be
careful because, again, data
was collected for
a certain purpose,
back to that issue of context.
But we may have a new
research question.
And so then, we search the data
and pull out the data elements
we need and reuse them.
And of course, we need to keep
an eye to reproducibility.
So if we go through this cycle
again with a new research
question, we have to
archive the data in a way
that we can reproduce
the analysis that we've
done with the data.
So when you hear the lecture
on data curation and version
control, you can
think about it, again,
how the data are described
and kept up to date.
The third topic you'll hear in
this series is on ontologies.
And this is actually
another example
of pulling some materials
from our resources
in our open
educational resources.
So this figure comes
from one of our modules
that's authored by Melissa
Haendel, some of you know,
who does a lot of
work in ontologies.
So in case you don't
know what an ontology is.
As it's defined in
our module and it's
defined similarly elsewhere,
a formal conceptualization
of a specified domain.
So clearly the terms
need to be defined.
Sometimes people
call things like MeSH
and other control
vocabularies an ontology.
I think the purists
would actually
argue that they're not.
MeSH is a fine,
medical vocabulary,
comprehensive
collection of terms
that are used to describe what's
in the medical literature.
But an ontology
structures the domain,
so you understand
the relationship.
So for example, you
see here that we're
looking at certain
types of neural cells.
And those cells or child are
more refined from the ones
higher in the diagram.
But there's a
certain type a cell.
So the hippocampal astrocyte
is capable of certain things.
And from a different
part of the ontology,
one that-- in fact this is
from the gene ontology--
describes specific functions.
And so the hippocampal astrocyte
is capable of those functions.
It also may have
some unique parts.
And it's also part of organs.
So for example, it's
part of the brain,
or it's also part of
the hippocampus, which
is part of the brain.
And then there are some
further refinements.
So in an ontology,
the relationships
between all the
terms are defined.
And this not only
organizes the data,
but it allows us to
make logical inference.
If, for example, a hippocampal
astrocyte is a cell,
there are certain
attributes of cell
that can be inherited down the
hierarchy that we can infer.
And this enables us to do more
sophisticated data queries.
Ontologies can be complex,
but they may provide
a much richer description.
And so the questions you
might ask with ontologies
is how we can optimally
index and then do retrieval,
using ontologies when we're
looking for data, but not
only for data.
Can we use these
also for looking
for literature and
other kinds of things
if they've been indexed
using an ontology?
The week that follows will be
taught on metadata standards.
There are many metadata
standards to choose from.
And sometimes they
duplicate each other,
which can be a problem.
But oftentimes they're
different because the task
that the metadata is
put to is different.
There's actually a standards
body, the International
Organization for
Standards, or ISO,
that actually has-- ISO is
the international standards
body of standards for many,
many things, one of which
is metadata.
There are standards for
metadata repositories
and other sorts of things.
In the information
retrieval arena,
there are a number of
metadata standards.
The Medline record
when we search
PubMed, or there's other
ways to search Medline.
The element, the fields,
in that Medline record
are metadata elements, so
the author names, the title,
the MeSH terms, the
secondary source identifiers.
All those things are
part of the metadata.
Medline is basically a
collection of metadata records
for the medical literature.
Another method that a
standard, some of you
may be familiar with is
Dublin Core Metadata.
Dublin Core Metadata
got its start
in the relatively early
days of the World Wide Web
in the 1990s.
It originally-- well, actually
still consists of 15 fields
that are actually have--
some of them have analogues
to what's in Medline--
so the creator,
the name of the resource, the
URI, which maps to the URL.
There's a field called subject.
There's also a
field called rights
that lists the rights management
in terms of who can access it.
And Dublin Core Metadata has
been extended, really built
on top of, by many, many
groups, one of which
is DataSite, which
I've already mentioned.
They have a metadata
for each data source.
And their system
for metadata builds
on top of the Dublin Core.
And then also groups
like bioCADDIE
that map among a variety
of metadata standards
with the focus on
biomedical data.
So whereas Medline has the
focus on biomedical literature,
Dublin Core had the focus
originally on web resources,
mainly HTML pages, but
expanding to other things,
bioCADDIE is focused
on biomedical data.
So one of the questions
you might ask in that talk
is what approaches
to metadata are
optimal for data indexing,
all the kinds of things
we might want to ask
about data resources
when we're trying
to retrieve them.
And then, of course, how do
we build retrieval pages.
Datamed.org is one approach.
And I know it's a
work in progress.
And what fields do they need to
add, what search capabilities,
and so forth.
The final topic in this
section is provenance.
And data provenance
is important.
Basically, data
provenance-- what is it?
It's where your data come from.
And whenever I talk
about data provenance,
I always like to
give an example.
And a few years ago, some
clinical informatics colleagues
and I published the paper
and some of the challenges
with using clinical data
from electronic health
records in research.
And just a number
of caveats, in fact
that's the title of
the paper, Caveats
for Using Clinical
Data in Research.
And provenance is one
of the big issues.
And I think this
will be an example.
And there's analogous examples
from laboratory experiments
and so forth.
But a simple
question we might ask
when we have a
clinical data source--
is a patient on a medication?
Are they taking a medication?
Well, there's actually multiple
ways that that's expressed,
and we really need to
understand each one and also
the limitations,
because sometimes
the physician might just write
I'm putting a patient
on this medication,
but there might not be an
order or prescription for it.
So once the order is
made, then the data
gets sent to a pharmacy,
either in the hospital
or if it's an outpatient to
a pharmacy in the community.
But again, there's not 100
percent of prescriptions
that make that journey.
Of course, they end up in
the pharmacy due to does
the patient actually get
the prescription filled,
and then actually do they
take the medications.
And in the hospitals, you
have things like medication
administration records.
And then also when, these
days, patients come back
to hospitals, we
have to do a process
of medication reconciliation.
So the point of this
is to really show
that there is many truths--
and I put truth in quote-- for
whether or not a patient
is on a medication,
and that can be really important
if we're doing a research
study where we're trying
to process the data that's
in an electronic health record.
And certainly any reuse of
data must take provenance
into account.
So I'm sure that those of
you who are more biologically
inclined can come
up with examples
like the one I've
given here of how
do we know what the
truth is, how do we
know where the data comes from.
And so when you're listening to
the lecture on data provenance,
you can ask things
like how do we best
describe the provenance
that's in datasets.
So at this point, I'm
going to continue.
We wanted to leave some
time for questions,
and I'm happy to
answer any questions.
As I understand it,
people can either
raise their hands electronically
or type questions into the box.
Dr. Jack Van Horn: Thank you, Bill.
So there's a couple
of questions that
are in the box somebody
has asked about.
They're asking about the
storage and retrieval
of experimental
data, also, are there
any standards or common
structures like HDF5.
And how does this relate
to open data sharing?
Dr. William Hersh: Yeah.
I have to admit I'm not
an expert in storage
of biological data.
I do know that
probably that area
is more developed than storage
of things like clinical trials
data, which may
sometimes just be
in very ad hoc kinds of ways.
That question, especially on
the specific data storage,
I would probably need
to defer to someone,
and maybe one of the
lecturers in the coming week
would be able to answer that.
Jack Van Horn: There was also the
question about how this all
relates to open data
sharing initiatives.
Dr. William Hersh: Yeah, sure.
Well, I think that open data is
actually really, in most ways,
really separate from
how you store the data.
When data becomes open,
the question, of course,
is how open it is.
Is it just sitting there freely
available on the internet
or do you have to file a
request with the originator
of the data?
If there is potentially
identifiable data
in there on people?
Do you have to go through
some sort of IRB process?
I think it all depends.
I'm an advocate of
open data, but I also
understand that
we need to protect
researchers who create the data
and know the context of it.
They should be
willing to share it,
but they also have some interest
in getting the most out of it.
And then, also, when we start
to get into data on people,
especially when we start
massively sequencing genomes
and if we don't have
ways to keep that data
private and deidentified.
We have to careful
for those things.
There's actually a
number of studies
that it's been shown,
sometimes, depending
on what data you
have, reidentify
people from so-called
deidentified datasets.
Dr. Jack Van Horn: It also looks like, Bill,
we
have some library scientists
out there.
And so a couple of them
have asked questions about
are librarians and
library scientists
being included on
data management teams,
and should they be?
And also how does the
ontological structures
that you've described-- how
do they link in with MeSH,
for example?
Dr. William Hersh: Sure.
I certainly believe
that librarians
bring important skills to
the groups that manage data.
I don't think that researchers
always realize the-- you always
hear stories about researchers
who lost their old data,
or they can't figure
out what the data was.
And that's why it's
important to bring those
with the kind of
expertise that librarians
have to make sure that your
data is documented well.
Metadata is there to define
what your data elements are so
that you have good
definitions and can go back
to your data in the future
through the metadata
to remember exactly
what the data is.
So there is absolutely
a role for those sorts.
And the second
question, again was?
Dr. Jack Van Horn: How do the
ontological structures
that you've described-- how
might they link in with MeSH?
Dr. William Hersh: Sure.
I showed you the
ontology of the cells
and the certain
neural cells types.
The individual items
in the ontology
should be in controlled
terminology, sets like MeSH
or other ones.
MeSH tends to go into more
details around diseases.
It tends to have more of a focus
on the biomedical literature.
But there's other
controlled vocabulary sets.
So the terms in
an ontology should
be from a controlled
vocabulary set.
And then if something,
say, indexes the literature
like the way that
MeSH does that you could then
map-- even though MeSH doesn't
capture those relationships.
But you would at least be
able to map from the terms.
And of course there's
another important resource
here that we should mention,
which is the Unified Medical
Language System, or UMLS, that's
been developed by the National
Library of Medicine.
The UMLS is a collection
of terminologies,
and there are basically synonym
linkages across vocabularies.
So if you find a term in
one control vocabulary
and it occurs in another, you
can use the UMLS meta-thesaurus
to map across those
terminologies sets.
So again, the terms
in an ontology
should definitely be from
a controlled vocabulary.
If they're not, they
should become part of one.
Dr. Jack Van Horn: Great.
We had a question
that you had mentioned
that you'd like to see more
clinical data being deposited
into open repositories.
And could you possibly
speak about the time frame
that you might see
this happening in
and which stakeholders
might drive it?
And also maybe comment
about how so doing would
help to encourage
reproducibility,
avoid misrepresentation
of data, and the like?
Dr. William Hersh: Yeah.
Well, I certainly support the
notion that data should be open
and people should
have access to it,
especially data
that's being collected
on projects that are
funded by the government,
by our tax dollars.
I do, though, think
we need to be careful.
And so there probably
needs to be a process.
I know, for example, in
some of the NLM databases
that have the genome
wide association studies,
there are processes where you
have to apply to get data.
The two things I think we
need to be careful with.
I don't think that
researchers should
be able to hoard their
data, but researchers
know a lot of the context of
the experiments that they run.
They spent a lot of time and
effort collecting the data.
So they should certainly be able
to get the most out of the data
when it's first generated,
the publications.
So certainly there should be
some period where they have
total purview over the data.
Then, when it's a
reasonable amount of time--
and you can argue how long,
six months, 12 months, some
say things like five years,
which is probably too long--
then it should go into some
controlled, released sort
of format.
I think it's especially
going to be true
as we do more things with
people that identify them,
their genome.
I know that there
are some methods--
and I'm no expert in them--
to partially de-identify a gene
variance and things like that.
But the reality is
that there will be--
and people showing you
can even-- the famous
study by Latanya Sweeney,
where she was able to identify
the governor of Massachusetts
in a health database
by purchasing the
voter registration
rolls for the city of
Cambridge, Massachusetts
and connecting him
through his-- I
think it was zip code,
gender, and date of birth.
So data should be open,
but it should be released
in a way that's controlled.
And I think there's
a role for IRBs
here to approve
these sorts of things
because there's always
another potential of someone
doing an analysis that is
not really justified based
on the context of the data
and getting different results.
I think there are still issues
to be worked out especially
when we start releasing
data that's originally
collected by humans.
But I certainly support
the notion of doing that.
Dr. Jack Van Horn: There was a question
about what does
the lack of consistent
ontologies across all
the medical domains from
practice to research and back
again.
Does that come at a
cost to the country,
and could you comment on that?
Dr. William Hersh: [LAUGHS] Yeah.
Well, I can answer the
question simply by saying yes.
But just to make some
additional comments.
Yes.
You see this now in the
clinical informatics world,
where I spend most of my time.
So we've finally,
after all these years,
have achieved widespread
adoption of electronic health
records.
Unfortunately, they don't
easily talk to each other.
Even when they can
exchange the bits,
the electrons of the
data, they don't readily
exchange the meaning.
And probably we'll never
achieve perfection on this
because different humans
interpret different things
about patients and so forth.
But a big part of the problem--
and the Office of the National
Coordinator for Health IT
has recognized this now--
is that we haven't really
adhered to standards, standards
onto elements and medical
records, standards on the terms
that we use to describe
diseases, lab tests, and so
forth.
And there are
standards out there.
They're not all perfect,
but they go a long way.
So I think that we need
to encourage standards.
And there's standards
processes that individuals
who really care about
them can get involved.
But we need to encourage
standards in a way
that we call something
the same thing,
or at least that
there's an identifier.
We might have different
ways of describing,
different synonyms for it,
but that they ultimately
map back to some identifier.
We should do that
as much as possible.
There may be some things
that change over time.
I commonly give an example.
When I was in
medical school, there
was no hepatitis C or D or
however many different types
of hepatitis.
It was all non-A,
non-B hepatitis.
And so terminologies
change over time,
and we need to model
the adaptation of terms.
But yes, we should strive to
use standards whenever we can.
It should be required by
the government, the funders,
the journals, et cetera, so that
we achieve as much use of it
as possible.
Dr. Jack Van Horn: Well with that point,
another question
was would you care to predict
or guess at the chances
that, in the future, a
literature will become
Pre-indexed with people
maybe preregistering
their studies against
particular data ontologies
or with particular methods.
Dr. William Hersh: Yeah.
Well, certainly that
possibility exists.
In fact, for clinical
trials now, they
have to be registered
in clinicaltrials.gov.
And certainly people who
are awarded NIH grants,
they know what they're studying.
So they could do
that free indexing.
Of course sometimes with studies,
you have unexpected findings.
So I don't know that the
indexing would totally stop
before the study was completed.
But that's certainly
a possibility.
And you can go search databases
like clinicaltrials.gov to find
studies on specific diseases
and treatments and so forth.
Dr. Jack Van Horn: I see.
Do we have any other
questions that are good ones?
I'm sure there's a
bunch here, and we'll
be delighted to share
them with you, Bill.
And maybe you can reach out
to the askers at a later time.
But it looks like-- sorry?
Dr. William Hersh: Yes.
Sure.
I'd be happy to do that.
We could even make it
publicly available.
I can type in the answers to the
extent that I can [INAUDIBLE].
Dr. Jack Van Horn: Yeah, that would be wonderful.
Well, let me bring
things to a close
here and thank Bill
for a fantastic
lecture in our second of our
data science seminar series.
Once again, let me
apologize to anybody
who had some difficulty
getting in initially.
As it might be clear, we
had a peak of 511 of you.
And as a consequence,
we had to make sure
that we could upgrade and
accommodate everybody.
So we had to update our URL.
The best way to find
the information is to go
to www.bigdatayou.o
rg/data-science-seminars
and follow the
instructions there.
And so this GoToWebinar
site will be the site
we always come back to.
So please spread the
word and come back.
And we'll see you
again next week.
So thank you very much everyone.
Have a great day.